[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture aujourd'hui nous
sommes au conservatoire de maurepas pour
fêter ses 50 ans voici le sommaire le
conservatoire de maurepas fête cette
année son demi siècle d'existence pour
célébrer cet événement des spectacles et
animations seront organisées
la commanderie des templiers à elancourt
accueille deux nouvelles expositions la
plasticienne viviane sagnier et le
photographe nicolas henry ils ont
installé leurs oeuvres et puis enfin le
mentaliste viktor vincent se produira
sur la grande scène du chéné rocancourt
samedi 22 janvier il présentera son
spectacle mentale circus nous l'avons
rencontré
[Musique]
elle
les
[Musique]
elle
on
[Musique]
je me trouve dans la salle ravel du
conservatoire de maurepas ici plus de
500 élèves sont inscrits d'environ 30
disciplines différentes 2022 marque les
50 ans du conservatoire et pour en
parler véronique rocher bonjour bonjour
vous êtes la maire adjointe à la culture
de mortain alors on veut bien sûr parler
du lieu mais avant cela est ce que vous
pouvez me peut-être me donner les
évolutions que vous avez peut-être que
constater du conservatoire alors là le
conservatoire a grandi avec la ville
déjà et puis la dernière grande
évolution c'est l'intégration de
musiques actuelles au sein du
conservatoire alors pour ses 50 ans j'ai
vu qu'il y avait une programmation riche
beaucoup de spectacles dont deux
spectacles de lancement est-ce qu'il ya
peut-être d'autres manifestations dans
la ville ah oui oui bien sûr les
manifestations ont lieu entre février et
juin
sur tous les lieux possibles de la ville
tous les lieux de diffusion mais aussi
un gymnase mais aussi une église
l'ancienne église ne mord pas
donc oui c'est ça va être riche tout au
long de l'année et c'est quoi ces des
spectacles qui vont être joués ils
différents spectacles différents on va
faire intervenir aussi bien le théâtre
que la musique parfois ensemble
différentes différents corps musicaux
enfin pouvoir est alors en quoi
finalement le conservatoire
est important pour une commune
alors déjà la musique est importante
pour chacun d'entre nous pour les
enfants pour faire grandir un enfant
c'est une discipline de vie qui me
semble essentiel dans l'évolution d'une
d'une personne donc à ce titre le
conservatoire a toute sa place donc il
ya deux spectacles en jeu disait un de
lancement dont un qui s'appelle
immersion 1972 et nous nous avons pu
assister à des répétitions regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
première répétition dans la salle de
spectacle pour les enfants les adultes
et l'ensemble des guitares du
conservatoire de maurepas qui célèbre
ses 50 ans concert d'ouverture des
festivités
immersion 1972 met en avant les musiques
de cette année la date également d'une
opération du conservatoire
on était avant le disco c'était encore
la grande variété et la grande variété
française claude françois michel fugain
véronique sanson donc j'ai fait une
sélection de petits morceaux et j'ai
fait des arrangements pour guitare cela
fait 33 ans que ce professeur de musique
enseigne la guitare au conservatoire de
maurepas c'est lui qui a eu l'idée de ce
concert il a en tout une soixantaine
d'élèves comme alexandra bridel qui joue
de cet instrument depuis 15 ans tous les
toutes les semaines on a une heure dans
semble donc pour s'entraîner sur ses
morceaux après là c'est vrai qu'on a une
quinzaine de morceaux presque et c'est
un très gros projet à monter on y est
depuis septembre
donc après avec les entraînements ça va
la spa du coup vous avez vu qu'on
s'entraîne avec les choristes avec les
musiciens donc c'est là que ça devient
un peu plus compliqué parce que c'est
vrai que quand on est entre nous c'est
facile parce que souvent vous entre nous
depuis des années deux fois par semaine
les élèves répètent entre eux ce concert
d'une durée d'une heure trente les
placent parfois aux instruments sans
chanteur associés
[Musique]
m
en ce moment vous entendez imagine avec
le thème au saxophone donc on a mis en
valeur différentes classes
instrumentales et puis moi pour les
chanteurs donc j'ai voulu faire
apparaître les voix d'enfants dans fais
comme l'oiseau
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
oh
les chansons seront entrecoupées de
saynètes théâtrales ce concert
d'inauguration sera joué vendredi 4 et
samedi 5 février à l'espace albert camus
à mort dont
[Musique]
julien pauli bonjour bonjour vous nous
avez rejoint vous êtes le directeur du
conservatoire alors on a pu voir le
sujet il ya donc deux spectacles de
lancement est ce que vous pouvez nous
les présenter oui alors les 4 et 5
février y aurait effectivement deux
spectacles de lancement du des 50 ans du
conservatoire le premier s'appelle
immersion 1972 puisque c'est l'année de
création du conservatoire il ya 50 ans
donc ça sera une plongée musicale et
théâtrale dans l'univers de l'année 1972
notamment autour des tubes musicaux de
cette année là donc on y retrouvera
l'ensemble de guitare du conservatoire
avec plusieurs autres disciplines
invités et les comédiens également et et
le second spectacle s'appelle tai chi li
té d'où il s'agit d'un conte musical qui
sera donné par des élèves du
conservatoire avec l'école élémentaire
des friches qui est une école de mort
ben d'accord très bien et à la rue
comment vous avez préparé tous ces
spectacles comment vous allez faire
alors déjà le la programmation c'est
fait
déjà il ya plusieurs mois où les
enseignants ont réfléchi à ce qu'ils
avaient envie de proposer pour ce 50e
anniversaire et ensuite chacun a
travaillé un petit peu dans son coin
préparer les partitions les élèves se
sont préparés les chanteurs les
instrumentistes là pour le moment chacun
répète encore dans son coin et on va
mettre les choses en commun très
rapidement pour pour les foires et pour
le 4 et 5 février
moi je voulais revenir aussi sur le
fonctionnement du conservatoire quelles
sont ses missions finalement la mission
centrale du conservatoire c'est
l'enseignement artistique c'est à dire
former des musiciens et des comédiens
amateurs jusqu'à un niveau même preuve
prêt professionnel
mais pas seulement c'est aussi une
mission d'animation du territoire avec
common voilà l'exemple des 50 ans des
concerts des spectacles qui participent
à la vie culturelle de la commune c'est
aussi des missions d'éducation
artistique en milieu scolaire puisqu'on
a des musicienne intervenante qui
interviennent dans toutes les écoles
élémentaires de la ville merci beaucoup
1 véronique rocher et julien foyer
d'avoir été notre invité à la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
à elancourt deux expositions sont
présentées à l'intersection une
installation visuelle et sonore réalisée
par la plasticienne viviane sagnier et
cabanes imaginaire et esprits de la
nature du photographe nicolas henry il
nous montre des récits portrait regarder
de curieuse forme sont apparus à la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
la plasticienne viviane sagnier a nommé
son installation alter spéc sion à
travers ces textiles entremêlés
l'artiste souhaite transmettre des
émotions je travaille sur la notion de
d'émotions et de sensations
donc tout mon travail se fonde sur la
perception que moi j'ai deux maçons de
mes sensations et de mes émotions et la
retranscription de plastique de ses
émotions initialement son oeuvre
invitait les visiteurs à toucher ces
matières mais il a fallu s'adapter on
travaille de manière générale et tactile
intégralement donc évidemment avec le
capitanat pas pu être possible tout ce
travail a été repensé pour qu'il soit
le vide cinglé l'installation est liée à
celle d'un autre artiste nicolas henry
le photographe plasticien et metteur en
scène y présente cabane imaginaire et
esprits de la nature son travail
artistique se construit en deux étapes
d'abord il réalise des interviews des
personnes qu'ils rencontrent au cours de
ses voyages
ensuite il met en scène l'histoire de
ces individus et les photographies à
partir de leur histoire qui soit une
histoire personnelle ou
communautaires ou là où l'histoire de
leur pays en fait j'ai cru des mises en
scène avec les objets que je trouve
autour de ces deux expositions se
rejoignent au sein d'une même thématique
c'est l'humanité l'être humain et il se
trouve que même si les deux les lieux de
travail présentés sont extrêmement
différents ça parle de ça des êtres
humains d'intimité du rapport aux autres
un vernissage est prévu le 12 février
prochain pour l'occasion viviane sagnier
interprétera une performance dansée au
coeur de son installation
d'autres expositions sont aussi à
découvrir dans les yvelines ah oui la
graineterie accueillera l'artiste
françois dufay du 22 janvier au 12 mars
le sculpteur réunira un ensemble de
sculptures machine d'envergure à
échelles différentes photographies
peintures ou encore aux broderies dix
artistes s'installent au salon de
l'hôtel de ville de la celle saint cloud
l'exposition artistique et scientifique
des arbres et des hommes est visible
jusqu'au 6 mars
mentale circus c'est le nom du troisième
spectacle du mentalist viktor vincent il
sera sur la grande scène du chéné
rocancourt samedi 22 janvier il
proposera une immersion dans le new york
des années 1920-1930
l'esprit humain est capable d'accomplir
de véritables miracles
le mentalisme c'est se connecter à
l'autre c'est écouter ce que l'autre dit
même lorsqu'il ne parle pas et nous
avons utilisé des choses rationnelles
pour créer des choses irrationnelles
comme la lecture de penser ou la
prédiction de l'avenir voilà ce qui fait
la force du spectacle mentale circus de
viktor vincent il sera sur la grande
scène du chéné rocancourt samedi 22
janvier c'est un spectacle où il ya des
démonstrations de mentalisme bien sûr
mais il ya aussi beaucoup de place mais
c'est au récit ça se passe à new york
dans les années 30 où je vais repartir
sur les traces d'artistes qui proposait
des performances mentales absolument
incroyable dans une époque elle même
incroyable et on va on va s'amuser à
revivre tout ça sur scène qu'elle
raconte est aussi l'histoire de deux de
ses personnages incroyables et c'est
dans leur histoire personnelle que qu'on
y trouve aussi de la vraie magie sur
scène beaucoup de performances
interactives un aspect important du
spectacle ce qui est amusant c'est dans
ce pays dans ce spectacle c'est que à un
moment le pouvoir entre guillemets
change de mains c'est à dire que ce sont
les personnages à les personnes qui
montent sur scène qui réalise les
exploits notamment une expérience autour
d'un calcul mental complètement fou je
prends une personne du public
et qui réalise mentalement quelque chose
créée en 2019 mentale circus mais aussi
en avant la musique très narrative venez
découvrir en famille ces fabuleuses
histoires et ces merveilleuses
expériences avec viktor vincent dans
mentale circus le mentaliste viktor
vincent sera en tournée dans toute la
france il reviendra dans les yvelines à
andrésy le vendredi 24 jours temps et
c'est la fin de ses 7,8 culture merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez vous la semaine
prochaine vnz aurait certes aimé 78
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]